Sunny hosted on The View admitted
whether accidentally or otherwise that
she committed voter fraud now this is
one person I'm not saying it's swing
swung impact or anything like that uh
and maybe if you'd like to make an
excuse for her as to what she meant feel
free to do so
but we had this um
this viral clip where she gets she's on
her phone and Whoopi Goldberg she's like
get off your phone you know Heavens or
whatever and then Sonny's like it was my
son he was he was messaging me to make
sure you know that uh I his absentee
about that that I did that and then it's
like it's a weird thing to say that I
did that like what does that refer to
and then she said I had trouble voting
for him today full stop she said she did
vote for him that is admitting to voter
fraud now immediately left personalities
came out and started saying she means
that she dropped off his ballot for him
it's like sure okay I get that where's
her son at where's her son that she had
his ballot and he couldn't drop drop it
off well apparently it was reported that
her son was in Massachusetts while she
was in New York
so why did the ballot go to the house in
New York you would have to believe that
the Sun
ordered an absentee ballot not to where
he is in Massachusetts which is what
absentee is for but to his own home in
New York where he could have just voted
in person but maybe he did it because he
knew he wasn't going to be there on
Election today but was going to be there
you have to believe then that he ordered
it went to visit his family filled
everything out signed it dated
everything sealed it up close it put it
down then left
then called his mom and said hey can you
drop my ballot off for me you'd have to
assume that he didn't just drop it in
the mailbox as per what absentee ballots
are for he didn't just take it with him
back home to mail that he literally went
home filled it out dropped it left I
think the simple answer Occam's razor is
that she committed voter fraud I don't
think voter mail-in voting is overtly
about voter fraud I'm not saying that
either the reason mail-in voting was was
the Democrats the reason Democrats did
so well right now nothing to do with
Trump they're saying Trump dragged the
party no establishment Republicans were
pulling funding from from Key races
everybody knows that and the bigger
issue is Democrat turnout was very good
youth turnout was very good and it's
this simple
mom goes to her Suburban mom goes to her
kids and she says kids our ballots came
fill them out and the kids say sure
whatever I guess who am I voting for and
just fill it out for the Democrats and
then they do those are real ballots
filled up by real people those kids
normally would not have voted they don't
know they don't care it has nothing to
do with them but their mom asked them to
now the steel man argument from the
Democrats of course is so what real
people voted what's your point my point
is people who don't care about the
system are voting and that's bad for the
system in the long run you can argue
that it's good because your policies are
winning but yo gas prices through the
roof inflation through the roof people
are not doing well and it's because we
have we have voters who have nothing no
stake in the system and don't care and
are only voting because it's just you're
tripping over ballots it's that simple
plus plus real quick and and I think 39
States about harvesting is legal so now
you have Democrat nonprofits legally
going to places where people normally
don't vote and saying fill it out and
I'll take it from you and that's
massively increasing voter turnout well
if you're looking at the Democratic base
this midterm election there was a lot of
unmarried women that heavily voted uh
Democratic there was also a lot of 18 to
20 year olds that voted uh in favor of
the Democrats over 70 percent of them
voted for for Democrats I think a lot of
this also has to do with big Tech
censorship and institutions like Tick
Tock Banning right-wingers and
conservatives and allowing other people
to have those kind of voices there and
when you have those key demographics
voting obviously they're going to be
voting in favor of policies we'll
shortly fit them but I also want to
point this out because for those that
are fans of the show you know I pointed
this out two years ago or a year and a
half
ago
if a Democrat nonprofit goes to New York
City Universal mail-in voting is
everywhere they walk into one tall 30-40
story building they knock on a door no
answer they spin around another door
knock someone answers within the span of
a couple minutes they could talk to
dozens of people within the span of an
hour they've talked to hundreds these
are legitimate votes and it's a
legitimate practice but Universal mail
and voting disproportionately benefits
dense urban populations if a republican
wants to go door to door they're mostly
in rural areas you'd have to get in your
car drive to a house knock on the door
no one answers get in your car driving
the next house that took five minutes
Democrats knocking a door no answer walk
10 feet knock on the door no answer walk
10 feet knock on the door so long as we
play this game of let's make it easier
for everyone to vote the procedure
outright favors Democrat strongholds now
DeSantis I think has proven
If he if you play the game right if
you've got good policy you can still win
if you win the cities so perhaps we
should either do away with universal
mail and voting because I certainly
think that's a big problem not because I
think people shouldn't be voting I think
it's a problem for a system when people
who don't want to vote just vote because
like people have to know what they're
choosing to do it you have a right to
own a gun doesn't mean every person
should just own a gun I think most
people should own a gun but just because
you have the right to do it doesn't mean
you know you can be just irresponsible
with it yeah
we're in a situation I mean look we've
got we've got I think that the election
system in America systematically flawed
uh you know the radical thing that I've
suggested over and over again is legally
we should just wipe the ballots uh the
voter rolls clear that everybody just
like your passports expired it's time to
go back and re-register let's see if
you're alive let's see if you're legal
let's see if you live where you say you
live let's go back there and see who you
should be there you should have to
register every election I I think you
should actually and you should go back
in there and you say okay I mean people
do that they renew their driver's
license they renew their passports they
do all these things I think that you
should have a voting day an election day
not an election season you should you
should register for every election by
going and be and and it can I don't care
if it's online quick 30 second thing to
be like this is my current address and
if you don't you don't vote yeah like so
back in the day we had voting where it
was like you had to be a landowner right
and you'd be a man okay so we don't
agree with those things today but you
need to understand the context back in
the day the the man thing yeah obviously
we've done away with with all that stuff
you know men and women can both go vote
19th Amendment but the reason it was
land-based was because we didn't have a
DMV to go get an ID right how did how
did we know you actually live there oh
you live in this house so you live here
yeah when we started moving into the
space of rentals and uh you know tenants
not ownership we're like okay well these
people they do live here we know they
live here they can vote so because we're
a community
what ends up happening is you had Andrew
Yang say he was going to move to Georgia
back in 2020 to help uh um who was it
who was running uh it was um
it was Abrams who was running against he
yeah he wanted to move to Georgia to
help the Democrats Warnock was running
yeah why not he so Andrea is like I'm
gonna move down there and it's like so
hold on you're not a member of our
community you're not voting for us for
what makes our lives better you're
voting for The Nation by moving into our
space yo that's crazy that shouldn't be
that way now however
you're allowed to move I get it that
being said I think it would make sense
if you were after every election voter
vote there's no such thing as a voter
rule you're not registered anymore when
election season comes Facebook and
Twitter and Instagram whatever can do a
reminder being like time to register to
vote and then you say yes I live here I
want to vote this place they say you got
it we've tracked your address then when
you show up you present proof that's who
you are and where you live and you say
that's me and they go send in your vote
yeah and it was all soft not worn out
you got 10 million people watching this
thing I got to correct that because I'm
the one that's wrong the Republicans
really do you know if they're good for
anything they'll
it
like what was it the HB what you know
it's like unfortunately all the voter
like any like they try to do I can't
talk anymore you finna I tell you I'm
like Biden I need someone to finish my
sentences for me I look at you don't
look at me I'm just as good as fetterman
and Biden I'm over here stumbling over
my words just what am I saying
is a weird telekinesis we have going on
I agree with Michael malice
um I don't know his full position on
fetterman but I think fetterman in the
Senate is a gift is a big big gift hear
me hear me people if the Republicans had
the Senate it would be better Ron uh RAM
sorry not Ron Rand Paul would be chair
of the health uh committee or whatever I
forgot the full name and that means he's
going to be able to you know ask some
serious questions about fauci and all
that stuff because he's done it already
but what could they really do there's a
chance the Republicans will take the
Senate with the Georgia runoff we'll see
but with Fetter men in this means the
real prize 2024
it's it's it's it's fetterman's an
advantage think about all of the videos
that are going to come out all of the
memes all of and it's sad really I mean
I don't like it that Biden is out of his
mind that fetterman is is brain damaged
these people shouldn't have run but you
know what they did so now the now
they're the Democrats are going to get
to withstand they're going to have to
figure out how to get past
two years of John fetterman not
understanding words
he you see the video where he said he
celebrated the death of Roe v Wade yeah
he's not with it and they got it
congratulations they're gonna have to
hide this man hey I've been calling for
him to run for president of the United
States we have Biden we might as well
have fetterman and MSNBC is joining my
calls officially saying hey fetterman
could could potentially be president
unironically no yes yes
I believe I tweeted it on my Twitter
page uh Luke we are change and it was
MSNBC it was the video that I started
off my YouTube uh no no I played it on
my YouTube video today as well it'll be
on my Twitter uh but but the memes they
they are very spicy already I I like to
post spicy memes but some of the federal
federal means are even too much too
spicy for me to be honest watch this
video wait wait wait gotta listen to
this video by MSNBC because they're
supporting what would I put out there a
couple weeks ago thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time